on appelle ça une veloruche c'est un axe
ou la chance la chaussée est entièrement
dédiée à la circulation des cyclistes
les voitures y sont tolérées mais sous
certaines conditions à tour la rue
d'Entraigues longue de plus d'un
kilomètre et demi est devenu cet été la
première vélo rue de la ville un signe
fort en voyant aux usagers du vélo mais
des désagréments pour les riverains des
rues adjacentes qui observent un report
de la circulation automobile on voit ça
avec Romain Delville
dans la vélorub mise en place début août
le système de portion de circulation en
sens unique alternée pour les véhicules
motorisés à contribuer à y faire baisser
le trafic des voitures mais depuis la
rentrée ces habitants de la rue François
Richer parallèles à la rue d'Entraigues
ne reconnaissent plus leur rue ni
s'inquiétude notre rue à nous se
retrouve être à un itinéraire de
délestage de la rue d'Entraigues avec
pour les automobilistes aucune autre
possibilité de joindre le boulevard
Tonnay que de passer par notre rue ou la
rue du Pla de l'État ce sont des petites
rues qui sont pas faites pour une
circulation aussi intense c'est
riverains considèrent que les nuisances
se sont déportés dans leur rue avec le
flux automobile cette vélo rue je la
trouve très agréable à vélo mais le
problème de la circulation n'a pas été
je pense pris en considération vraiment
il aurait fallu
repenser avant penser à tout ce flux de
qui doit quand même être pris en compte
quoi le même constat est dressé par des
riverains de la rue du Plat d'Etain rue
valvain ou encore rue Victor Hugo les
habitants du quartier se sont constitués
en collectif les oubliés de la véloru
pour faire entendre leur voix sur un
sujet où ils ont le sentiment d'avoir
été mis de côté on s'était dit qu'on
attendrait de savoir les réels effets de
cette ville sur notre rue à la rentrée
et on n'a pas été déçu puisqu'elle a la
rentrée c'est devenu invivable
l'expérimentation de la vélo rue
d'Entraigues doit durer 6 mois un
comptage des véhicules est en cours sur
différents tronçons à la mairie on
assume l'idée que la circulation
automobile soit entraverue d'Entraigues
et déportés dans les rues voisines dans
l'espoir qu'à terme les 3500 voitures
qui circulaient se réduisent comme peau
de chagrin dans le quartier l'idéal ce
serait qu'il y ait des personnes qui ne
prennent plus leur voiture
peut-être que les gens vont trouver
tellement compliqué finalement je
passais par là pour amener mes enfants à
l'école bah peut-être que je peux y
aller à pied peut-être que je prends les
transports en commun peut-être qu'à
terme pour modifier les usages il faut
beaucoup de temps donc c'est pour ça
qu'on laisse 6 mois comme ça les membres
du collectif les oubliés de la vélo
russe seront reçus en mairie le 9
novembre et compte faire des
propositions pour mieux répartir les
flux dans le quartier la mairie qui de
son côté l'assure des aménagements à la
marge sont possibles mais la vélorub
entre restera